this program is being presented to you
by the hereas international winter
school on gravity
and light
so we'll have a short lecture
investigating cosmology at
later times we studied cosmology at
earlier times at least we made an
observation we studied cosmology in
general
and we looked at a consequence at early
times and now we look at later times
and we will now consider
various types of meta at the same time
now consider various meta types
simultaneously
because as already some of some of you
asked
um what happens if you have several meta
types present at the same time that's a
realistic situation
you cannot say oh let's assume the
universe is made of photons well it
isn't
there's lots of stuff in the universe
and you have to consider that
but um
um so let's recall
however uh what we learned we learned
that if we have equations of state
that are linear and i will not go away
from that because we're writing down
simple models of course if you're a
cosmologist
you may have many many reasons to
generalize what we're doing here
and the purpose of these introductory
lectures is to give you a taste and the
basic ideas
and of course with whatever assumption
you're not happy
you go and generalize it and of course
people did that so for instance i was
asked in the break
what happens if you drop some of the
killing symmetries
well then you get non-isotropic
universes for instance
and then you get other models so for
instance they're the bianchi models of
the universe
we looked at the so-called friedman
robertson walker model it's the
homogeneous and isotropic
cosmology so many such generalizations
of course are being looked at because
cosmologists
try to understand the data nevertheless
some amount of modeling is always
involved because you need to make an
abstraction from the local structure
which is extremely rich
and for them you cannot if including
every detail you simply cannot solve the
einstein equations
so some amount of modeling is always
required but of course you can be very
clever
and say i do not make a model by just
writing down
something i make a model by really
trying to derive this from fundamental
principles and so on
of course the better a cosmologist you
will be anyway so the purpose of these
lectures is to give you the basic ideas
and the basic ideas
if we make our assumptions explicit
there is nothing dishonorable about
making
such assumptions it is an assumption
nevertheless
you know the game so our equations of
state
i will always assume that this is
this one for omega equals constant and
from that we will now not deviate
so for each meta type and then for each
meta type you may have a different
omega i i equals one to
number of meta types that you
do have okay fine so obviously then you
have different pressures and different
densities for precisely those meta types
okay these different equations of state
now however what we have learned we
learned
that independent
of the meta type
it's true that h squared
scales like the density scales like
a to the minus n of omega
and what was the omega let's make again
our little table
and maybe this time i would ask the
blackboard
erasers to maybe not delete this table
for
a while
okay so you see the erasing procedure is
not homogeneous it needs to be right up
there
okay good so this is the omega
and obviously we had
obviously we had radiation
so let me write here what the meta type
was
the type was radiation
then we had omega zero that we called
dust
that was pressureless fluid we had
a minus one was a cosmological constant
well let's leave it there okay we do
radiation dust and cosmological constant
and or maybe i want later on the omega
copper two
yeah and we have the um the spatial
curvature
but let's not consider spatial curvature
as meta because we're going to rewrite
the friedman equation
uh you know especially the acceleration
equation in a way
that will uh use the spatial curvature
separately okay so let's take these
three types you add your favorite other
type
if it makes any sense um but there are
these numbers n
appearing n of omega and n of omega was
three times
n of omega was three times one plus
omega
so instead of remembering the omega
we could remember the n n equals
omega equals zero n equals three
omega equals minus one n equals zero
omega equals a third that's three third
plus one third is four
thirds over three is four
okay so let's have uh these guys here
um i don't know what i wanted to put in
the in the other
column it doesn't matter it's a nice
empty column right okay
so please do not erase
um ah well one could put in the uh
the time evolution but um yeah why not
okay so let's say what what's the a
of t how does the a evolve and uh we
found that for the cosmological constant
it was special
it evolved exponentially like this for a
constant age
and for the others it was this power law
a of t
was t to the 2 by n
t to the 2 by n
is here
yeah it's square one half aha yeah of
course
n is for one half um t to the two by n
is two thirds exactly so those were the
this is the
scale factor how it evolves for
radiation how it evolves for dust
how it evolves for a cosmological
constant that is something we found out
um we further found out
that for all matter types
not equal to cosmological constant so
that's an exception
the row invariably went like
t to the minus 2. that's stuff we
observed right
that's just from this homogeneous and
isotropic
universe okay
now let's make a definition
i already wrote it down it's the hubble
function
so so this is all you need to know okay
and all that now comes is terminology
but it's terminology that's heavily used
and it makes the equation simpler so why
not use it
the hubble function is simply the
function h of
t that is a dot by a
that's the hubble function okay
and the hubble function has to do with
the age of the universe
why well if the rope goes like the t
to the minus two from this we learn and
that we will show in the tutorials right
um you will you can show that h
goes like t inverse
and you know that at t
equals zero boom
big bang aha
so and this guy can be measured because
it has to do with the expansion of the
universe the hubble
function which in this case is a hubble
constant if you have only a cosmological
constant otherwise the function
and so it's related
roughly speaking
h inverse is the age
of the universe
and it's a rather remarkable number
that you can measure the age of the
universe first of all it has an age
because it has a birthday
right the big bang is the birthday of
the universe
let's hope we don't celebrate it ever um
so okay it's it's quite remarkable that
you can calculate this from this theory
who would have thought that
einstein didn't set out to calculate the
age of the universe
it's a rather preposterous aim but
nevertheless it drops out
okay so that's the hubble constant um
but then there are more
interesting objects and
they're called density parameters well
there may be functions
but for linear evolution laws
for linear equations of state like those
they're actually constants
so let's call them parameters but keep
in mind that
in this jargon you should never ever
deduce anything
from what it is called you only look at
the definition
and so you have a density
parameter density parameter
for matter
of density
rho say well if you have the density why
do you need a density parameter
well you like to normalize this in a
certain way
you call this omega now you may have
several meta types i
write a small i and you know in here the
i
always runs from one to number of meta
types
okay so for each meta type that has a
density rho i which is every everyone
you get a density parameter capital
omega i
and this one first comes with
a bunch of constants a p 8 pi
g n third why do we put them
well of course they're not relevant
they're just there because we use that
later in the
the equations become perfectly simple if
these constants are absorbed in here
okay but that of course meaningless it's
just a rescaling
and then the relevant thing is that you
have the density in there linearly
so that's why it's called a density
parameter because the density scales
linearly with the density
but it's normalized with the hubble
constant squared
or the hubble function squared so unless
you're in a
in a purely cosmological constant
scenario and no other matter present
this is really scaling by a constant um
but if you have other meta types you
know the hubble constant isn't quite
that constant it's it's a function
right it goes like t minus one
and um and then we like the scaling
because this is a nicer quantity if we
plug it into the equations
we're going to rewrite the equations
using these guys
so this is for the meta types
as a matter of density but it doesn't
work
for the fake matter that makes spatial
curvature or the
if you have a spatial curvature i said
you can consider this as fake matter
uh or if you have a cosmological
constant it's like fake matter
with such a um equation of state where
the omega is minus one
right i mean actually only matter is
only this stuff here
and different models and the
cosmological constant didn't come by
putting it in an energy momentum tensor
it came from the other side of the
einstein equation but you could think of
it as a contribution to the energy
momentum tensor
and then it would correspond to a fluid
of omega is minus one
you look critical julian
what's strange it takes taking a term
from one side of the equation to the
other side
second grade it's not strange no no it's
not strange
the cosmological constant comes in in
the einstein equations
at the level of the action as an
addition here
and square root minus g plus you add
a meta lagrangian not lagrangian density
because you already
took care of that it's the associativity
of
addition that allows you to do this
and yeah that's it
okay good so um
it's not strange to do that it's maybe
surprising that it works
but from there it's clear it does okay
so
therefore one also associates density
parameters but according to a different
formula
with the cosmological constant and with
the fake
curvature with the curve spatial
curvature which now really doesn't come
as matter into the game right i mean
so for the cosmological concept you say
okay it comes into the game as matter
but that the spatial that the spatial
curvature of your underlying three space
for which you have three choices
that that can be understood as a meta
contribution i mean that's really just
looking at the terms and saying it looks
like matter
for a certain omega okay
you can do this but now once you've
defined these density parameters
you have to make extra definitions for
the density parameters
they're also called density parameters i
call them fake density parameters
because they just absorb something under
the same heading
which has actually a very different
origin question i'm wondering
so what's the physical
meaning okay okay yes so the
cosmological constant i could just call
matter
so for the cosmological because i added
here whether i say add it here that has
historical reasons
rather than adding it to the metal
lagrangian but of course it could
equally well be part of the metal
lagrangian that's the associativity of
addition here
so it's an artificial distinction to say
it is not in the meta it's in the
geometry
what do you mean you have an actual
there's a sum
how who are you to tell me right
this belongs to this rather than this no
of course not well you and that's
exactly your point right they say what's
what you mean by fake matter
so for the cosmological constant it's
as good matters all the rest it's a bit
of a funny matter
because it's everywhere of of negative
pressure
but on the other hand if you have a
rubber band it's also of negative
pressure now you have a rubber band and
you stretch it
and has negative pressure because it
pulls you in
is there any physical meaning of the
energy momentum
logical the energy momentum tensor for
um for the cosmological constant uh is
uh the cosmological constant times the
metric
because you vary with respect to the
metric and there are maybe some dressing
factor here
roughly speaking okay one second i say
one more
thing now so you could say well here the
cosmological constant i call it fake
matter because the
the term looks different but that's
still you could still consider it matter
that has the same right but now however
if you start talking about the curvature
the spatial curvature kappa
which we have three choices zero plus
one or minus one
if we absorb the scale into the scale
factor
i mean that is strange because it
doesn't appear anywhere in the
lagrangian
well of course if you plug in a special
solution to the field equations appears
but it comes from a
totally different point it comes from a
symmetry assumption gives a restriction
you have three
types of anzacs you can make now
you say the unsuch i make is matter is a
meta type
that's a little strange right so um but
formally you can do that and then you
can
forget about the difference between one
and the other
and treat them all the same and measure
all the same and say this contribution i
associate to this and so on
so that that's so that that certainly
determines
deserves the name fake fake density but
i said that's my personal terminology i
mean you
you might equally drop that yes
something like gravitational force again
because i mean
in the newtonian picture way gravitation
had
something like a meaning of force and
would put things
together but i mean we got rid of it
because now
it's curvature of space but if you
introduce something which
now pulls something together this is
like
introducing again something like a force
in this new tile no no because because
no because the cosmological constant
i mean that's the intuition understand
the negative pressure but the
cosmological
constant appears in here i associate to
the energy momentum tensor it
contributes to the meta contents of the
universe
and that curve space time even more or
differently
okay so you add it and the role it plays
here is that it
curves best and more therefore all the
the particle trajectories are modified
as opposed to you don't have a
cosmological constant
in that sense it has an effect it should
have an effect
but it's not a force it just contributes
to the curvature
via the einstein equation okay fine
so um let me write down this uh
okay omega equals minus one did we
already
put in the assumption that we assumed to
be greater than zero
no no because we will now write down the
lambda explicitly in the density
parameter
no no we didn't okay so um
we have the first fake density parameter
that's for the spatial curvature copper
so that deserves the name fake for the
spatial uh
curvature kappa so if it is present we
think we have a fake density present
which is omega kappa so kappa is not
included into the one
two number of meta types it's an extra
type
is minus um kappa
over h squared
a squared we just have to define it that
way
so that we can treat this at the same
level and the third
is then uh the pseudo fake so not quite
such a fake
um so let's put in brackets the the
pseudo fake density parameter
but i agree that's that's that's
ridiculous it could also be called the
density parameter but for the
cosmological constant you have to write
it down in a different way
it's called omega down lambda and it is
um lambda by
3h squared lambda
by 3 h squared so
the point is ignore the terminology what
i call the density parameter fake
density parameter i call it the flower
concept
it doesn't matter you have on the right
hand side of these definitions
you have quantities you know and you
well understand
that are defined that have a physical
meaning and on the left hand side
you obviously have a combination of such
quantities and we
it's nicer to work with these
combinations for the following
reason using
the hubble function
and the density
parameters
we get well first first of all we get
for the friedman equation
we can rewrite it and look
how nice it looks i take the sum
of all meta types from one
to the number capital i of the meta
types and number of meta types
is capital i
and i add up all the density parameters
for meta type 1 meta type 2 meta type 3
but i didn't want to call the coppers
meta types but i call so you could say
over all non-fake matter so let's make
really say not fake here let's only say
fake density parameter here
so you could also say it's the sum over
all
non-fake matter
so that includes the cosmological
constant meaning from one
to i but the fake matter you also add
okay you'll see in a second why i do it
like this anyway the sum of all of this
is one that's the friedman equation you
can
check so that is more memorable i guess
than the original friedman equation okay
so this is why one likes this but then
we have another
equation we had the equation which
requires an
acceleration excel flowration
equation what was that that was this a
double dot
and that becomes h inverse
squared a double dot over a
you could also set out to rewrite the a
double dot over a
using the the h but let's leave it this
way
equals minus one-half
sum over all non-fake matter
so including cosmological constant but
not including
the curvature of one plus 3 omega i
so the omega from the linear equation of
state
makes a reappearance times the omega i
so you see that using the density
parameters
both equations take a rather simpler
form
and that is why cosmologists like to
think of the meta types including the
cosmological constant
as meta types and even in this equation
they like to also think of the spatial
curvature which you may choose to be
zero which means that this omega
copper goes out or you may choose it to
be plus one or minus one
okay they like to think of it as the
same level
so you say some all matter fake or
non-fake it's one
the density parameters but down here is
only the non-fake matter
okay so
you you have this and you say okay you
re defined these quantities
what's the point it looks nice but
what's the point
well you can ima immediately look at uh
what i call
for me that's what should have been
called density parameter and hubble
function
okay so that was section one here
density
parameter
and hubble function
it's just these redefinitions and the
friedman equations
in those terms and then the next
step is the second
dominant matter
at various epochs
so stages of the evolution of the
universe
so now you could think that you have to
postulate which
matter is dominant in the early universe
from your physics intuition and which
matter is
more important later on in the universe
from your physics intuition
in fact you don't need the intuition you
can calculate
we know
that rho
goes like a to the minus n of omega
right so we know the density of the ith
meta type
goes like a to the minus n
of the omega of the nth
metatype omega is a constant
now we also know that's the first thing
you know
the second thing we know is the not
erased
table here but maybe the rest could
slowly be erased
um maybe the left the left blackboard
we know that the various meta types
radiation dust and cosmological constant
they have different
ends so let's write down the ends
what is the n for radiation i write n
gamma like a gamma quantum
right and gamma is four right that's
what we had is four
for radiation uh then we could have the
n the next lower one is three that's the
one for
for dust and uh here i write in m like
matter
but what i really mean is dust that's
the terminology
in cosmology matter and here we mean
radiation
okay that is three from the table
then you also can get from the table
that the n
for the kappa if you include it in the
ticket in the table
would be a 2
and the n for the lambda is actually a
0.
for the cosmological constant so this is
the n you would
formally associate with the spatial
curvature
and that's the n you would associate
formally
with a cosmological constant okay
and this is true for any meta type
including cosmological constant
remember i emphasized some of the
equations i wrote down
are only valid for non-cosmological
constant matter
but this one in particular is true for
all matters see the
tutorials today where you will derive
this a very short derivation
it's good to do this yourself
no we didn't assume ah
no this should be for any kappa yes
that's the end it's the the density
parameter for the kappa
carries the kappa and carries the sign
uh you're right i i think i wrote in
this table
in the last lecture i i wrote something
like this
no no no sorry that's that's minus one
third i'm sorry i'm sorry
no no the sign goes in the omega yeah
yeah
i was confused there now now i see now
that you ask
and that's just minus one third and the
sign comes from the omega in a second
okay so um now you have that
and from that you can immediately
conclude
that the following is true you can
conclude that the density
associated with the cosmological
constant which we just defined
scales like a squared
the density associated with spatial
curvature
which in turn is proper it may mean
proportional to that is what i mean
proportional to
with a constant factor proportional to a
squared omega kappa which in turn is
proportional to
a to the third omega matter
so that's the dust which in turn is
proportional to
a to the fourth omega for radiation
this follows immediately if you check
the definitions of these
of these density parameters and what we
wrote up
here if you plug in these ends here and
check how the density parameter
parameter has to row in there it's very
obvious
okay so think about this it's very easy
okay
aha now this
is simply an observation but it's an
observation that tells you a lot
why does this tell you a lot
well
observation
in an expanding universe
that means a universe where the hubble
function
is at all times greater than zero
because it's a dot over a
that means the a increases all the time
that's an expanding universe in an
expanding
universe the later the time the bigger
the a
right
t 1 less than t 2
if and only if a of t 1 less than a
of t 2 at later times there's a bigger
scale
factor right very simple it's an
expanding universe
but if that is true then how
do look at just this proportionality
here
for a second you can look at any of
these but let's look at this one
there's an a to the third as an a to the
fourth so you can of course divide by a
to the third
what remains is omega m scales like a
times omega gamma right
so they're they're the same so which is
more important at late
times this one which is higher this one
or the omega gamma
the matter because the matter is
a thousand omega gamma or a million or
ever increasing that means
if you have hence
we read off
that if you have here time
which we now know starts at the big bang
great
this one if you go forward in time
the ones to the left here become ever
more important
and if you at the beginning of time
where the scale factor is very small
this one is the most important one that
means in the early universe the gamma
dominates the others may be there
but they are suppressed
so then slowly the gamma is less
important and the matter starts to
dominate
and then slowly the matter is even less
important this is even further less
important and the spatial curvature you
may have chosen or not to be there
or that maybe they are not dominates the
evolution of
the density and at very late times only
the cosmological constant
the term determines is the dominant
matter type in the universe
that plays the biggest role
so i didn't have to speculate about
the role of a cosmological constant in
the early universe
there is none it's highly suppressed
there would only be a role in the early
universe if all the other meta types
weren't there
then of course it remains the dominant
one because it's the only one
okay it's a political solution if you
eliminate all your competitors right
then you you stay dominant
everywhere right but but that's the only
possibility
otherwise the other one starts to
dominate
and that is a result of the theories not
a modeling
assumption that's good
that's good so we have better control
over the various epochs
so if a cosmologist says well lambda
dominates
at late times it's a very mysterious
statement unless you know this line of
proportionalities implied by the
friedman
and acceleration equation um
that's this okay fine so you have the
these dominant meta types at various
times yes
do you know any later time than now
that's that's the terminology we're at
late time
we're at late time okay
i mean you could say if we weren't at
late time maybe we couldn't have
observed this yet right
if there's other stuff present because
then this might be still dominating and
we have that stuff
and that's the standard model that's our
assumption
whether the spatial section is flat
spherical or hyperbolic
and we'll see how this fares with uh
observations yes
so but we speak only of if we have
different types of
meta which are dominating at which time
but we do not speak about converting one
type into the other
no no not included not here no no that's
not included
that's right you may want to look at
that and people in fact people look at
that and
their conditions on nuclear synthesis
and stuff like this and you need a
deceleration period but not
as a second derivative is less than zero
and so on so there are many many results
they're all based on the model that's
right i mean
obviously one needs to look at this this
is a very simple-minded
model that uses several types of matter
yes
because this spatial curvature we're
talking about
is obviously not caused by mass so we
just assume
we're living in a sphere or a saddle or
a blood space
and that's it yes it's there it isn't
it's there it isn't but if it's there
assume the spatial universe is
s3 it's closed as a finite volume assume
that's the case
then that doesn't play a big role in the
early universe
and it doesn't play a dominant role in
the late universe
but it plays a role somewhere in between
well not not for late and not for early
but for in between it is
okay and whatever processes take place
here so you can say
when did i don't know the stars develop
what was structure formation
when was the cosmological microwave
background being imprinted
in the quantum fluctuation blah blah
blah blah blah blah right
when what took that place and you you
try to
to figure out when happened what because
of all the physics you know
which is more physics input and then you
slowly get a picture and this is already
very rough pictures
of what could have been the most
dominant meta type
density wise density parameter wise at
which stage
it gives a first order first ordering
principle to what you're looking at
and obviously cosmology is a fascinating
and very big
business today not only a business a
fascinating subject it's
extremely complicated because you need
to take everything into account
from quantum field theory uh plasmas but
what not the whole business this is the
uh
the zeroth order approximation to to
what's going on
yes
yes experiments say something and i'll
i'll show in the diagram in a second
um
does this mean that well the meta is not
dominating
so this uh canvas interpreted as
okay we take some galaxy cluster and
according to its gravity
it evolves and does stuff but this
i don't know about any galaxy as little
as somebody dealing with a gas
who dealt with gases at the time
who were these people who who did the
gas laws what were they called uh
tell me name help me what boil
okay boyle didn't think about atoms
at this level i'm not thinking about
galaxies i'm thinking about the fluid
from very far away
but you say okay the matter in our
universe has no
impact or nearly no impact on the
evolution of the universe as a whole
at our time now because we are less less
impact yes
not the dominant impact yes yes that's
right
i no longer i no longer have the
resolution of i don't even see a galaxy
cluster
as little as in this room you see uh uh
um oxygen
okay in atoms universe we have now uh
the matter
evolves according to the laws of gravity
but it has nearly no impact on the
evolution of the universe as a whole
because
i mean it's trying i'm trying to draw to
to make a metaphor
for what actually is this exact line of
proportionalities
i'm trying to bring them to life but if
you need to go back to this to answer
any specific question yes so
obviously the density of matter is being
reduced a lot
by time in proportion to the density of
the cosmological constant for instance
it's proportionality it doesn't tell you
anything about the absolute value
okay so maybe it's just this
proportionality then but um
i just wonder how we can met at all
like dominant matter at all as we have
um if it's being reduced that much
well we do have yeah but as i said i
mean the point is you have a very thin
very non-dense met i mean
i'm in this room you have a lot of air
okay that's one fluid and there's
another fluid that's all your noses you
know
we'll come back to this topic so the
point is
all your bodies and now the point is
what contributes more to gravity in this
room to the space-time curvature in this
room
your bodies or the height the oxygen
molecules uh
molecules well you you do
okay so you have several types of matter
and here we're in a situation
where you contribute more to that then
you could have another situation right
where you have i don't know
with a very dense oxygen gas filled with
a very dense oxygen gas you wouldn't be
sitting quite so happily here
but it's the same audience then all of a
sudden it could be so dense and it
contributes more to gravity than you do
and in the evolution of the universe
these proportions
in a sense these dominances density-wise
they change according to this line
yes it fades away
so the oxygen will fade away with time
and our bodies will fade away less
well it depends i mean it depends also
on the statistical mechanics of this
how does it thin out if you make space
double as big
how does the density of a radiation
change compared to the density of
point bodies you look at this in
statistical mechanics you get different
results
that the scale dependence the volume
dependence
is not the same for different meta types
so this is in perfect accordance with
say statistical
considerations because some are massive
they have a different phase space than
those that are
massless has to do with that yes
the larger the universe grows the less
important the matter becomes
that's somehow clear but what's the
interpretation of the cosmological
constant then
is it is it this dark matter well
yeah so some people say um
i like to think of photons and little
balls that don't interact and curvatures
but this guy i can't imagine and it it
aids
some people's imagination to invent
names
and so you can call this dark energy
and then they say well it's a justified
name because it's an energy as you can
see well energy density and you have a
dark
because the cosmological constant is a
meta type i added to the energy momentum
tensor
but none of the other matter has the
lavender in it
do you know the lambda where's the
lambda in the maxwell action
in jackson it isn't there the the
so the the light doesn't couple to the
lambda
roughly speaking okay so the lambda
stays there separately alone
not coupling to any of the other matter
okay
so that means you couldn't detect it by
other matter because you can only detect
something if it interacts
i can detect your head by throwing a
ball if the ball is reflected but for
that the ball needs to interact with
your head
right if it doesn't i have a problem
with detecting your head
okay or with the light and so on so if
the lamp that doesn't couple to anything
else in your other matter actions
which is something we haven't seen okay
then
it's dark because you can shine any
matter on
it it's not being reflected because it
goes straight through it
okay so therefore it's dark energy we
don't see it
other than through its gravitational
effect because it contributes to the
energy momentum tensor
hence the met the the einstein curvature
sees it but that's the only thing that
sees it hence it's called dark energy
and then you can say well anyway i'll
show a diagram in a second
but that's just the name dark energy and
then people could say oh it could have
different types of dark and
what do you mean by dark energy well for
you can call this dark energy that's
terminology i try to avoid it
yes if it is a constant in the ancient
equation
doesn't it mean that it is perfectly
homogeneously distributed
that's right that's right yes yes it is
like the ether
okay that's polemics but but but the
point is it is that's right
that's right
the background independence
as giulini in his evening talk in his
inofficial evening talk
explained um one has to be very specific
of what of what
means by background independence because
you can
make any equations background
independent in a sense
well any matter you put on somewhere is
extra structure if you wish
i i think this question is uh not
particularly meaningful it depends on
how i look at it if i say
well if you provide this density omega
omega's
the energy then uh of course you have
provided one right so
how is it still background independent
it provides a background
but it depends on what you call a
background it's rather
at this stage of technical definition
it's a rather ill-defined question i
think
sounds good but that's the case with
many questions
in the yes how then can i see a
gravitational effect in
smaller scale because the sun i know
okay there will be some effect but it's
distributed now you see the you see it
at the global scale now
if you only have a cosmological constant
the evolution is like e to the ht
right and it blows up not by light
deflection
now of course by light deflection
because if the universe changes in time
light is a time like null geodesic
well depending on what the whole overall
circumstances are and so on
of course you see it also there yes but
not in a spatial
affiliation yep but in a space but in
spatial foliation you see nothing
because the experiment needs to use
massive or masses particles
and they always are transverse to
spatial
the model that we sections uh all all
the things
are uniformly isotropic and everything
but of course in real life matter
texture
and even radiation you can have pockets
with more radiation so
would it be possible that also dark
energy also
memories like this or buying the
construction
of course so some people say okay
let me continue because i first need to
i always want to give you answers that
already depend on an experimental result
i'm trying to show you in a second right
so um okay so let's see another urgent
question
okay good so um
so let's look at a realistic late
universe well
i shouldn't say realistic i should say a
more realistic
late universe
i mean these are all toy theories and
they can be slightly refined
so a realistic late universe
several meta types
present so let's assume
we have matter
spatial curvature and a cosmological
constant
yeah let's say that um
that is a three-dimensional parameter
space
that we have for these parameters but
the friedman equation
says the sum of the three is 1
that means i could express for instance
the omega kappa
as 1 minus omega mata minus omega lambda
the friedman equation says if you have
three density parameters
you only need to look at two because the
third one is then determined by the
friedman equation
right aha so
that is hence
the parameter space
for this model
is omega m
omega lambda because the third one is
automatically
determined you only need to track these
two now let's draw
a picture of this
so here i have the omega lambda
and here i have the omega m the density
parameter
for the dust for the pressureless matter
which i imagine fills the universe
and here i have the density parameter
for the cosmological constant
which i assume might be present
i don't know how much of this and i
don't know
how much of that and i also have
presents
the omega kappa but the omega kappa
i don't need to look at because if i
know a point in this space like this one
i know there's this density for that and
that density for that
that could be an observation do you
agree i could look
now and ask what's omega m and omega
lambda and that's in fact what the
various experiments extract from their
data
on the basis of the model very
importantly not absolutely
but on the basis of the model they
extract that from their data so very
important
caveat right okay and then i know the
omega kappa because it will be one minus
this minus that
is the omega kappa so now
the cosmological constant this guy here
is proportional to the cosmological
constant if you go back to the
definition
um let's look at this in the range
from minus one plus one we'll see in a
second y
and let's look at this in the range from
zero
to two you'll see in a second why
okay so we have this model
here now i can ask various questions in
order to understand the space of
possible measurements
an observation would measure a point i
mean a sufficiently
precise observation so classify the
regions
in this parameter space classify
the regions in this
parameter space and obviously if you say
hey you forgot the omega gamma what
about the radiation in the universe i
say yeah okay
then draw a three-dimensional diagram
you have the omega gamma
in there still the omega kappa is then
one minus omega m omega lambda minus
omega
gamma right then you get a
three-dimensional graph and you have to
put a point into a three-dimensional
graph
okay but if we are interest in the late
universe
the omega gamma is long not more no more
interesting you remember
so we leave it out in the model why
would we bother let's do a two
dimensional graph
okay good um
right so classify these reasons in this
parameter space
and the first thing you could ask is
um consider regions
of spatial curvature
copper either greater zero but i would
also like to know the region where it's
less than zero
and i would like to know the region
where it's equal to zero
aha how did this go
well k equals zero kappa equals zero
corresponds please check the definition
of omega kappa
corresponds to omega kappa being zero
right
because it was proportional to kappa the
omega kappa
if one is zero the other one is zero aha
but omega kappa
is one minus omega m minus omega lambda
agree why the friedman equation
hence i have
omega lambda equals this is 0
equals omega m
minus 1.
which line is that omega lambda is
omega m minus 1.
is this this is wrong at that right it's
one minus omega m
omega lambda goes to the other side is 1
minus omega m
what line is that that's
this one here
right so this
straight line here
in a suitably curved blackboard plane
this is a straight line
this straight line here
are all the observational
data points i could have which would
yield
kappa equals zero
you see it's just a line and anything
to this side of it you can check
has kappa greater than zero
you check by the same argument but
instead of the equal sign you take the
other sign
and everything to this side of it has
kappa
less than zero
you need to look very closely to see
whether it's zero or not
but anyway that's what you can have
these are the two sides here
then you can have another i can ask
another question
you could ask the acceleration
of the expansion what is that well
that's
h to the minus 2 a double dot over a
well this one is always positive this
one is always positive
so if you are just interested in the
sign it doesn't matter what the factors
in front are
you can again ask where is it less than
zero where is it greater than zero and
where's the acceleration of the universe
zero
where does the expansion accelerate
where does it not
and where does it decelerate that's
interesting to
look at now we look at the acceleration
equation so this was
friedman this here was the friedman
equation
and now we have another equal sign now
we use the acceleration equation
and what was that there was something
like minus one half
the sum over all non-fake meta types
i equals one to capital i um
three now um uh uh
one plus three omega i right yeah one
plus three omega i
omega i aha so i only take the non fake
types equals
minus one half now the first type
i want to look at is the only non-fake
types are m and lambda
they're meta types right m was
uh dust which omega does just have
zero p equals zero rho
because it is pressureless has zero so
the first one is
one plus zero times omega
matter plus so that means a minus
one half next type is the lambda
what omega did the lambda have
minus one one minus three
is minus two minus two times minus one
half is plus one
plus one times omega lambda
you agree
think you do agree so you have minus one
half
omega m plus one omega lambda
so again from starting from this equal
sign if you want to get the line here
from here it follows omega lambda
is plus one half omega m
aha so if before we drew this
yellow line that was the line for kappa
equals zero
and now we draw a blue line
that's the one for acceleration
equal to zero and it's omega lambda is
one half
m it starts here goes to the middle
goes to up here
that's this one so this has on this line
the acceleration of the expansion
of the universe
well the acceleration of the scale
factor is zero
and you can again do the same
calculation and check the signs
if you go in this direction the
acceleration
is greater than zero and if you go in
this direction the acceleration of the
universe is less than zero
you can ask further questions you can
ask
in what region what about re-collapse i
think this answer this question was
asked before right
re-collapse versus
eternal acceleration
i mean it seems very reasonable so you
say our universe expands
but there's matter in it i mean matter
and energy
and okay some energy has this funny
negative uh
pressure type thing the cosmological
constant but shouldn't
the energy in there the matter
try to lump together again it flies
apart
but shouldn't finally it fall together
again
and that would then okay so i mean
that's the question that you can ask
so the so that you can say there is
recollapse
if and only if there exists a time
t star in r plus zero
please keep it i i need this it exists
does there exist a time t star in r uh
zero such that the expansion
of the universe
actually comes to a standstill and
actually also that this is not only this
but this is a maximum
know that the a is a maximum
that the second derivative also vanishes
and so on so anyway
you know what i mean you look at the
scale factor right this is time
this is the a is there something like
this so there needs to be a turning
point
and of course you can write this in
terms of an equation right you can ask
when is the second derivative of the
expansion
zero and if it's supposed to be a
maximum so that really goes back i mean
it could come to a stencil and then
go on then you know that you need
the first derivative to be less than
zero
no something is strange here the first
derivative is zero and the second
derivative is
is is less than zero for maximum right
okay thank you okay so as i said
undergraduate
calculus all replaced by differential
geometry no
no no kidding so so the point is you
find the condition
for this turning point and you can write
it down and look what the equations say
um that can be written down it's a
little bit more complicated
what you find is the following so you
find
the condition that the collapse just
doesn't happen so the division line
between re-collapse happens and eternal
acceleration
happens is the following
the division line runs along here
really exactly along here and then it
takes off a little here and that's a
complicated function which however can
be analytically calculated
some are cosines in it and so on and
everything above here
is eternal acceleration
eternal expansion and everything
down here
every down here is re-collapse
it only depends in this model on the
omega m
and the omega lambda
now you can investigate well omega m and
omega lambda actually constants well it
depends on your model
in our model they are because in our
model
recall
that the row went like t
to the minus two and the h went like t
inverse and you have in the densities
the omegas are rho
by h squared quite obviously
okay anyway so we're here and now the
question is what does experiment say
this is all theory
these are possible universes we might
have
filled with this toy matter what does
the theory the observations say
and the observations from various
sources
and cosmologists believe from
independent
sources not independent groups but in a
sense one is supernova galaxy surveys
and redshifts and whatnot indicate
that omega lambda is
0.7 and
and omega m is 0.3
hang on a second yes and kappa omega
kappa is zero because it lies exactly
on this line and of course it's an
experiment right
so the experiment rather says something
like this and says our universe
is somewhere like there
so um you might say well to a very
big degree kappa equals zero a flat
universe
that means spatially infinitely extended
is supported but i mean it's very easy
to
to jump here to jump here right okay
and um 70 percent
of the energy density matter energy
density of the universe
70 percent needs to be put in the
cosmological constant
and only 30 percent comes from
matter but it's even worse
so observations
say one hundred percent that's the one
in the friedman equation
equals zero percent from the spatial
curvature
spatial curvature
contribution and of course
there may be a little space place a
curvature plus
70 percent is the cosmological
constant contribution this is in order
to explain
the totality of observations or a
certain sub totality of observations
plus now there's 30 percent left but the
are split in 25 plus 5
which we divide for other reasons and
only these 5 percent
come from what we believe is standard
model matter
standard model of particle physics
matter
so if we don't look into the universe
and we go to accelerators and we
shoot bananas onto oranges and we see
what happens
and we study all the products of these
of these collisions we get all the
particles of the standard model
that's what we get this is quantum field
series the three
uh gauge feed not three gauge with the
three gauge theories and
or the electro weak and the uh strong uh
interaction and all the the zoo
of of of of particles that come with it
but that what we believed in quantum
fields here in elementary particle
physics
to be all the matter there is
at high energies as high as we can
produce them in the lab
what we believe is all the matter there
is
only accounts for five percent of the
matter
and energy in the universe that you need
in order to explain the observations in
cosmology
don't steal the moment so now
the remaining stuff is not of this type
and it has certain properties and people
call it dark
matter because like the cosmological
constant we introduce which is just one
model for dark energy it's a
dark matter and i can call this dark
energy
it's just terminology right
it doesn't interact with any of that
matter but all our instruments are made
from that matter can only interact with
that matter so it could be that dark
matter interacts with dark matter i mean
it
very likely does and so on but the point
is we don't have
instruments built of dark matter so we
can't detect whatever dark matter is
deflected by dark not deflected is is um
scattered by other dark matter we can't
detect it so it's dark for us
it's dark because we don't have the
right instruments okay
um and if we had the right instruments
that were made of dark matter
maybe i could still not read off the
dial because i have no dark matter in me
so
if it really doesn't interact it's a
problem but gravitationally it has an
effect that's why we see
certain things so i mean this is
dramatic
because well the zero you can forget
because it says
that 95 of the stuff
of the matter energy density that fills
the universe
if einstein's theory is correct because
all of this all the interpretation of
the raw data
this diagram more complicated models
they all depend on einstein's theory
plus our theories of the standard model
of particle physics put together in
combination on craft space-time
all of this relies on that and if
there's no mistakes have been made
the theory says that what we always
believed is all the matter in the
universe
is only five percent so you can
if you believe firmly and einstein
gravity
and you believe firmly in the standard
model of particle physics put on curved
space-time
being treated they're right and people
who calculate the stuff having made no
mistake
if you believe in all of that which is
quite reasonable to believe
conservative point of view right
we have a major discovery here from
recent observational data of the last 20
25 years
we discovered 25
of matter in the universe in the last 25
years
which before went undetected
this is why people are so excited about
this
they say if this is true but it always
comes with a caveat
if the underlying theories that have
been used to extract
this splitting of numbers are correct
einstein theory being one of them
and of course remember i said
maybe you cannot make the symmetry
assumption first and then calculate
maybe you have to do this in another way
and there are people who claim you need
to do that
so some people say maybe some amount of
this
maybe not everything but maybe the
proportions
shift a lot if you do the good old
physics properly
so maybe einstein theory being correct
quantum field theory being correct
and also people not having miscalculated
who calculated the background theory for
that
but maybe they made a mistake in line
one
okay and therefore it's very valuable
what some people try that they say don't
make the symmetry answers too early
it could be that if you average later
that this
shifts and maybe then this is 25 95
and this is five and you say yeah yeah
there is something
okay okay and now you have to work on it
and
you know i mean also the smallest
mercury procession can take you
somewhere you know
four arc seconds per century so we
couldn't just shouldn't discard this
but this major result would look
different
okay so always keep in mind what it's
based and always
question where else could this come from
but of course it's excellent for
research grants i take it
so therefore um you follow the standard
route so anyway
so you have you have this this result
um in the universe
that's different what yulen is referring
to is
and should have emphasized this more if
you have
a field equation and einstein gravity is
not
an exception then you should always
insert symmetry assumptions
on the objects about which the field
equations talk in this case
on g you should always insert it at the
level of the equation
if you remember julian is talking
symmetry is something that takes a
solution to a solution
but this here comes from an action
namely as grav
plus s matter this total action by
variation with respect to all
possible fields that are in there and
you could say oh
i could implement this already up here
and then i only need to vary for
instance in cosmology
with respect to the scale factor because
that's the only degree of freedom that
survives
this here is usually illegal you must
not insert a symmetry answers into the
action
and then derive and it's pretty clear
why
think of actions in in classical
mechanics there you say
you call this curve special or solution
of your equations
if any neighboring curve however
slightly it deviates
um now if slightly deviating neighboring
curves
don't change the value of this guy to
first
order right that's the stationarity
principle
but now assume i put in the symmetry
hundreds from the beginning then i can
no longer compare to this graph it's
crucial that you say
any neighboring curve that deviates only
a little
shouldn't change the value by more than
a quadratic order
not just one but any but now imagine you
put in the symmetry answers first in
that case for your curves
you would only compare to other curves
that satisfy
a certain symmetry condition
then you're comparing to fewer
competitors
if you compare to fewer competitors you
can be more easily better
so the point is you can have fake
solutions
if you insert it here okay that's the
point you can have fake solutions
so this is not allowed but there's the
principle it's um the principle
of symmetric criticality
or stationarity but tradition is called
criticality
it's by palais and he gives conditions
under what conditions you can plug in
the symmetry
and very roughly speaking if your
symmetry algebra
you know that the symmetry comes with an
algebra for the metric if the symmetry
algebra
is the algebra of a compact group how do
you find whether it's the symmetry
algebra of a compact group
well you calculate the so-called killing
metric it's the same killing but a
different object
you calculate the so-called killing
metric from the
structure constants of the algebra
so we have the structure constants of
the symmetry algebra you remember
you square them up down down
up down down you contract this one with
that one and this one with that one and
then this a and b
remain open you call the result k a b
it's called the killing metric i think
if it's negative definite
then the lee group to that lee algebra
is compact i think that's right
so you very quick i give you an algebra
for instance our our rotation algebra
you could check this guy is a negative
definite 0-2 form
and then you know ah so for a symmetry i
can do it because palais says
for compact groups you can do it and
then vary and it's the same
but it's a very rough statement and it's
only sufficient and
application requires sufficient care but
roughly something like this
but that's right but in general that's
what julian i think you you
meant yes yes is you're not allowed to
do that
but that has nothing to do with
cosmology
yes is it possible that these dark
matters are just
ordinary particles but unseen by us
cold or just hidden somewhere yes so
some people consider that they say
it could be the standard model over
again
but with a little slash on each particle
and the slash has no interaction terms
with the non-slash
particles yeah but that's dark matter so
nobody knows how to model that in detail
i mean something like astro
astrophysical objects like
match or something like this is it
out do we know it's not true there are
many possibilities uh
these trump this is it's
it's not believed that it's uh of
standard model type
but again who knows okay but it doesn't
look like it
it simply doesn't look like it okay is
there a static solution on this graph
a static solution you mean where the
universe does not expand
well you need to you can you can check
you can require
a of t is constant
and you know that rho goes like a to the
minus
n you know that h goes
like a square root of rho
you look at the densities and you look
how they need to go
if if that's possible at all such that
there is
uh that this the solution is static yeah
you can check that yeah
okay so i think we need to postpone any
questions to
after the pizza event thank you